digamos que tomamos una pequeña
excursión a la luna y nos encontramos
sobre la superficie lunar así que aquí
está la superficie lunar y digamos que
también en nuestro pequeño viaje en
nuestro pequeño viaje llevamos dos cosas
la primera de ellas es un tabique
digamos un tabique de concreto aunque
ahí está un tabique de concreto y otra
de las cosas que llevamos es una pluma
de un ave que digamos que éste es la
pluma de algún ave
muy bien entonces ya que estamos en la
luna uno podría hacerse la siguiente
pregunta podríamos digamos que soltamos
tanto el tabique como la pluma a la
misma altura entonces la pregunta sería
cuál cae primero y en principio de tu
experiencia en la tierra vamos a más o
menos hacer ese dibujo digamos tenemos
un tabique aquí
y nuestra pluma muy bien tenemos tabique
y la pluma muy bien entonces de nuestra
experiencia en la tierra nosotros
sabemos o más bien hemos visto muy a
menudo que el tabique pues caerá
directamente hacia la superficie de la
tierra sin embargo la pluma no la pluma
da como un movimiento más o menos así no
más o menos va para acá y luego para acá
ya después en cada uno de esos
movimientos cae un digamos una parte y
aquí está la superficie terrestre
entonces el detalle aquí o más bien la
diferencia que tenemos en este ejemplo
sobre la superficie de la luna es que
aquí no hay aire muy bien y es que todo
este problema de cómo se mueven los
cuerpos en realidad se ve muy afectado
por la presencia del aire pero en la
luna no hay aire así que esto nos va a
ayudar mucho para poder realizar digamos
o responder la pregunta de cuál caería
primero sí
el tabique o la pluma entonces para
poder checar esto vamos a calcular
primero las fuerzas que interactúan con
estos dos cuerpos digamos que esta vamos
a llamarle la fuerza la fuerza del
tabique del ladrillo y a la fuerza que
actúa sobre la pluma la fuerza
gravitacional vamos a llamarle
efe ep muy bien entonces calculemos cada
una de ellas quien es la fuerza de
nuestro tabique y aquí en realidad estoy
pensando en la magnitud verdad en la
magnitud de este vector pero bueno para
no ponerlo así vamos a quitarle solo la
flechita aunque ya estamos pensando en
la magnitud de la fuerza y nosotros
sabemos por la ley de la gravitación
universal que esto es igual a nuestra
constante g mayúscula que multiplica a
la masa de la luna que multiplica
después también a la masa del tabique y
dividimos entre la distancia al cuadrado
que hay entre
centro de la luna y el tabique muy bien
entonces a toda esta parte a esta parte
digamos que tiene a estas constantes le
vamos a llamar g que es el campo
gravitacional de la luna
ok este digamos voy a quitarle la
flechita este es digamos la magnitud de
la aceleración debido a la fuerza
gravitacional es el campo gravitacional
muy bien si nosotros calculamos la
fuerza
digamos que que corresponde a la pluma y
déjenme otra vez quitarle la flechita
esto a quien es igual nuevamente es por
la ley de la gravitación universal es la
nuestra
nuestra mayúscula por la masa de la luna
que multiplica la masa de la pluma y
dividimos entre la distancia al cuadrado
entre el centro de la luna y el centro
de la pluma muy bien y si se dan cuenta
aquí también aparece
traje lage que es la aceleración debido
a la fuerza gravitacional en la luna
aunque que es el campo gravitacional
ahora bien ya con esto podríamos ir
calculando cuáles son las fuerzas que se
interactúan con estos dos cuerpos sobre
la luna verdad la fuerza correspondiente
al tabique es igual al campo
gravitacional de la luna por la masa del
tabique verdad por la masa del tabique
mientras que la fuerza correspondiente a
la pluma será igual a la al campo
gravitacional de la luna por la masa de
la pluma muy bien entonces vamos a
suponer ahorita algo vamos a suponer y
digo esto es algo muy muy muy intuitivo
de suponer es que la masa del tabique es
más grande que la masa de la pluma
abordado uno podría imaginarse muy bien
que la masa de este tabique es mayor que
la masa de la pluma entonces como
las fuerzas que interactúan con estos
dos objetos si nos damos cuenta están
siendo multiplicados por la misma
constante quiere decir que la fuerza de
ponerlo con el color que va que la
fuerza correspondiente al tabique es
mayor que la fuerza gravitacional de la
pluma entonces uno podría pensar bueno
tenemos una mayor fuerza sobre el
tabique lo cual eso podría decirnos que
por eso es que cae mucho más rápido el
tabique que una pluma pero ojo
tenemos que considerar algo en este en
este ejemplo a pesar de que la fuerza es
mayor también tenemos que considerar que
la masa del tabique es mayor verdad
entonces también hay que recordar que a
mayor masa mayor resistencia tiene el
objeto al movimiento verdad es más
digamos es más difícil hacer que ese
objeto acelere muy bien y entonces si
ahora realmente queremos calcular la
veloz lo más bien la aceleración que
llevan estos dos cuerpos sobre la luna
y recordar que de la segunda ley de
newton la fuerza es igual a entonces la
fuerza es igual a la masa por la
aceleración muy bien así que si nosotros
queremos calcular la aceleración basta
con dividir de ambos lados entre la masa
verdad aquí esto se cancela y lo que nos
queda de hecho aquí podríamos ponerle la
flechita verdad la aceleración es igual
a la fuerza entre la masa muy bien
entonces cuál sería la aceleración cuál
sería la aceleración de digamos del
primero hagamos del delta byc como lo
hemos estado haciendo hasta este momento
la aceleración del tabique será igual a
la fuerza a la fuerza del tabique entre
la masa del tabique verdad pero quién
era la fuerza del tabique era justo el
campo gravitacional de la luna por la
masa del tabique por la masa del tabique
dividido entre la masa
del tabique y que para suerte no está
nuestra estas dos se cancelan y
simplemente nos queda el campo
gravitacional de la luna ahora ya yo
creo que ya te imaginas a dónde vamos a
llegar
qué pasa si calculamos la aceleración
correspondiente a la pluma pues esto es
la fuerza de gravitacional de la pluma
dividido entre la masa de la pluma ahora
quién era la fuerza correspondiente de
la pluma era el campo gravitacional de
la luna por la masa de la pluma la masa
de la pluma dividido entre la masa de la
pluma y esto nuevamente es el campo
gravitacional de la luna así que podemos
concluir que cuando soltamos estos dos
objetos en la luna
al mismo tiempo llevan esencialmente la
misma aceleración verdad llevan o caerán
a la misma proporción quiere decir que
van a caer al mismo tiempo si es que no
hay aire y entonces a lo mejor tú te
estarás preguntando bueno esto en
realidad no tenía nada que ver con la
luna verdad
aquí pudimos haber puesto el campo
gravitacional de cualquier lugar de
cualquier planeta pero sí y ya lo mejor
podría esto funcionar en la tierra el
detalle es que si funciona en la tierra
siempre y cuando pudiéramos absorber
todo el aire que tiene en la atmósfera
si nosotros no tuviéramos aire en la
atmósfera entonces es al tirar un
tabique y una pluma al mismo tiempo
sobre la tierra caerían al mismo tiempo
sobre la superficie de verdad el detalle
aquí es que hay una resistencia con el
aire por ejemplo si este tabique digamos
que lo aplanan y lo hacen algo muy muy
muy delgadito aunque pero que tenga la
misma masa ahí están algo muy muy muy
delgado entonces al soltarlo y no caer a
la misma al mismo tiempo que este
tabique original y eso es porque este
tabique tiene mayor resistencia al aire
verdad debido a su forma y en cambio si
nosotros agarramos esta pluma y la
comprimiera nos digamos todo lo
comprimimos en un
único punto entonces este punto caería
mucho más rápido que esta pluma pues
ofrece menor resistencia al aire ok
entonces sólo para ir terminando este
vídeo te voy a invitar a que hagas un
experimento muy interesante
digamos agarra un libro supongo que
tiene que ser un libro que no te guste
digamos ahí está tu libro
y este libro
aquí hay un libro que sea más o menos
pesado ok ahí tienes un libro y agarra
una hoja de papel
digamos que ahí está tu hoja de papel
sube a la azotea o algún lugar que este
elevado quizás en alguna ventana y tira
los dos objetos al mismo tiempo y verás
que va a caer primero el libro antes que
la hoja eso eso eso debe ocurrir pero
ahora en la siguiente ocasión vas a
poner la hoja encima del cuaderno o de
este libro lo vas a poner sobre la
portada y tirarlos al digamos así juntos
y lo que vas a ver es que como la
resistencia al aire que ofrece el libro
se va a disipar entonces estos dos van a
caer al mismo tiempo pues la hoja ya no
va a tener resistencia al aire